Let's go with the first question in Spanish,
what is it
and what is the goal that you have as
consul of las velas
my objective is the well-being of
Mexicans in las vegas' one of the
priorities is consular protection
I want all Mexicans
their rights are respected it does not matter if
you have papers or not you
have rights and they must be
respected that is one of my priorities
another of my priorities is that the
family is well that they have access
to health education in the different
modalities as well  is that I am going to work
very closely with the entire Mexican community
and with the local authorities
so that this happens
ok the other question is what are some of
the good ones what are some of the
challenges that this consulate is
facing and what is  plan to
change here
the pandemic is a challenge it is a
global challenge and it is impacting our
daily life I would like more people to be
able to come to the consulate to obtain their
documents  cough and obtain information,
however, that is not possible due to the
pandemic and this virus, which is very
dangerous and we must not lower our guard
, therefore the challenge is how to reach
more people through social networks through
traditional media such as television
and  That is why I am very grateful for this
space and the radio, but above all the
social networks. In
any case, there are people who do not
have access to social networks, do not
have access or do not have time to
watch Facebook or Twitter or some other,
so that is the great challenge.  and I want to
work with the organized communities
to help me spread the message and
the word that the consulate is open
both physically and virtually
thank you with sun and
in the time you have been here which
you have seen is one of the
most urgent needs  important for the
nationals who come to ask the consulate for help,
well right now there is a great need for
documents such as passports,
popular license plates and cr
ine voting essentials there are also
labor needs people are
losing their jobs they have lost their jobs and need to
pay the bills pay the rent
so we are informing
them where they can get help they should
know that people who are in a
high degree  of vulnerability they can
have access to some kind of help from
us they are exceptional cases case by
case and only really high
vulnerability
but well there is help there is information and
the invitation is to come to the
consulate and that is more or less what I
asked you at the beginning  what are
some of the resources that the consulate offers
if the consulate is a
very rich information center we have
health information education
information information on access to
financial tools we also have the full range
of consular services
passports growth we register children we
marry people
we give powers of attorney for mexico in short it
is a wide range  a number of
possibilities that they can have access to and as I
told you a moment ago, if someone
has a problem with the law, they have
a lawsuit and they are in immigration detention, they
are in jail for some
other reason, we also have help for
them, thank you and
the last consul  question, it is already an important
year for all Latinos here in the United States
and within the pandemic we are seeing
that a presidential election is coming, as
well as the census count in the
Mexican consulate, which is doing
how it is, informing the
Mexican nationals who live here for
how  You communicate with them to
inform them about these important events.
We inform the
Mexican community of all the events and
situations that are relevant to
them. For example, in previous months
we were talking about the census because
everyone here in the United States should be
told about  the election because there
will also be general information it is important to
note that consumers  Both sides and the government
of Mexico are not involved at all in
the electoral process and not at all in
politics, but without a doubt, whether it is a
fire, an election or a parade,
any type of event or situation that
is important for the Mexican community,
we spread it in a way
responsible and objective and something that you
would like to add so that the
las vegas' community knows about you
well I want you to know that the new
consul of mexico is as always
open to all of you my doors and
my phones are open I want
you to come to the  consulate that they have
confidence that they look for us they will
find information they will find
resources and I want them to know that we must not
let our guard down this pandemic is
active this virus is very dangerous we
do not know what to expect from it so we
have to have a lot  Be careful and
follow the instructions of the
local authorities